- [Voiceover] Hello
grammarians and hello Paige.
- Hi David.
- So today, we're gonna talk about
the three different
ways to end a sentence.
This is what we call a terminal
punctuation of English.
Paige, what are those three ways?
- So, the first is a period.
- Okay.
- And then exclamation point.
- Poom.
- And a question mark.
- Swoosh. Poom.
- A period is
just sort of the standard
ending to a sentence.
- Sure.
- Right, it's...
It goes at the end of,
I think, most sentences.
I would say that all of the sentences
that we have spoken so far
would probably end in periods.
- So what's a good example sentence
that we can use a period at the end of?
- My mom ate a cookie.
- So that's just sort of a
straight up, regular ol' sentence?
- Yeah.
- Just a standard declaration of a fact.
- Exactly.
- This is a thing that is
true. My mom ate a cookie.
- Yes.
- Cool, and then we just
put this period there to say
that's the end of a...
End of line.
So then what is, what is
an exclamation point for?
What would we use that for?
- Yeah, so an exclamation
point is pretty much
if someone is excited
about what they're saying.
- Okay.
- So if I were to say
I'm gonna eat so much
candy when I get home!
I think that was probably an exclamation.
- Sure.
- And ends in an exclamation point.
- But its not just like
good excitement either.
It's not just like, wooh, this is awesome!
- Totally. There can
be, you know, anger like
go to your room!
- Right.
- Or like fear. If you said...
- Aaah!
- Yes. Exactly.
- We have the period,
which kind of all purpose
terminal punctuation you
can just say a regular
declarative sentence. Here is a fact,
my mom ate a cookie.
Or you can use exclamation points to
demonstrate excitement or strong emotion
whether good or bad, so
like an interjection like
aaah! Or a command like go to you room!
Or if your super excited,
I'm gonna eat so much candy!
What is this thing used for? Huuuh?
- Well, I think that was a perfect example
but that thing is used for...
That is a question mark which
goes at the end of a question.
So it basically just signifies
I don't know the answer to this thing
and I would like an answer to it please.
- So okay. So Paige,
what's an example question
that we can throw out
using a question mark?
- How about, is this edible?
- Well it's the eternal question.
(Paige laughs)
- I ask myself that everyday.
(David laughs)
- Okay so we have periods,
just statement of facts,
exclamations, expressions
of strong emotion,
or question marks, which
ask a question? I guess?
(Paige chuckles)
- Yeah.
- Cool.
Thanks Paige.
- Thank you for having me.
- You can learn anything. David out.
- Paige out.